l'attitude des états unis à l'égard du
programme des sous marins est une
nouvelle illustration du constat que
nous faisons depuis des mois
c'est qu'aujourd'hui le dialogue
politique est inexistant au sein de
l'alliance atlantique
[Musique]
jamais depuis l avènement la 5ème vic la
france n'a connu une telle humiliation
mais force est de constater que cette
affaire dit des sous marins australiens
en dit long sur votre gouvernance est
votre bilan
[Musique]
la raison d'être de l'otan ce n'est pas
la confrontation avec la chine la raison
d'être de l'otan c'est la sécurité
transatlantique et c'est ce que nous
devons rappeler aux états unis
l'alliance atlantique a un coeur de
métier ce coeur de métier c'est la
défense collective de l'europe c'est
l'article 5 les etats unis jouent un
rôle essentiel
mais la france aussi qui joue son rôle
en témoignant de sa solidarité par
exemple auprès des états baltes dans le
cadre d'opérations de présence de l'otan
[Musique]
c'est donc dans cette logique que les
alliés ont décidé à notre initiative
ainsi qu'à celle de l'allemagne
d'engager une révision du concept
stratégique de l'alliance est rallié ce
n'est pas être l'otage des intérêts de
l'autre